The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseware
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseware
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: This
lecture is not
relevant to this
exam or any exam.
It's time-dependent quantum
mechanics, which you probably
want to know about,
but it's a lot
to digest at the
level of this course.
So I'm going to introduce a lot
of the tricks and terminology,
and I hope that some of
you will care about that
and will go on to use this.
But mostly, this is
a first exposure,
and there's a lot of derivation.
And it's hard to see the
forest for the trees.
OK, so these are
the important things
that I'm going to
cover in the lecture.
First, the dipole
approximation--
how can we simplify the
interaction between molecules
and electromagnetic radiation?
This is the main
simplification, and I'll
explain where it comes from.
Then we have
transitions that occur.
And they're caused by a
time-dependent perturbation
where the zero-order
Hamiltonian is time-independent,
but the perturbation
term is time-dependent.
And what does that cause?
It causes transitions.
We're going to express
the problem in terms
of the eigenstates of the
time-independent Hamiltonian,
the zero-order Hamiltonian,
and we know that these always
have this time-dependent
factor if we're
doing time-dependent
quantum mechanics.
The two crucial
approximations are
going to be the electromagnetic
field is weak and continuous.
Now many experiments involve
short pulses and very intense
pulses, and the time-dependent
quantum mechanics
for those problems is
completely different,
but you need to
understand this in order
to understand what's
different about it.
We also assume
that we're starting
the system in a
single eigenstate,
and that's pretty normal.
But often, you're starting
the system in many eigenstates
that are uncorrelated.
We don't talk about that.
That's something that has to do
with the density matrix, which
is beyond the level
of this course.
And one of the
things that happens
is we get this thing
called linear response.
Now I went for years
hearing the reverence
that people apply
to linear response,
but I hadn't a clue what it was.
So you can start out
knowing something
about linear response.
Now this all leads up
to Fermi's golden rule,
which explains the rate
at which transitions
occur between some initial
state and some final state.
And there is a lot
more complexity
in Fermi's golden rule than
what I'm going to present,
but this is the first
step in understanding it.
Then I'm going to
talk about where
do pure rotation transitions
come from and vibrational
transitions.
Then at the end,
I'll show a movie
which gives you a
sense of what goes on
in making a transition
be strong and sharp.
OK, I'm a spectroscopist,
and I use spectroscopy
to learn all sorts of
secrets that molecules keep.
And in order to do
that, I need to record
a spectrum, which basically is
you have some radiation source.
And you tune its frequency,
and things happen.
And why do the things happen?
How do we understand
the interaction
of electromagnetic
radiation and a molecule?
And there's really two
ways to understand it.
We have one-way molecules as
targets, photons as bullets,
and it's a simple
geometric picture.
And the size of the target
is related to the transition
moments, and it works.
It's very, very simple.
There's no time-dependent
quantum mechanics.
It's probabilistic.
And for the first 45
years of my career,
this is the way I handled an
understanding of transitions
caused by electromagnetic
radiation.
This is wrong.
It has a wide applicability.
But if you try to
take it too seriously,
you will miss a
lot of good stuff.
The other way is to
use the time-dependent
in your equation, and
it looks complicated
because we're going
to be combining
the time-dependent
Schrodinger equation
and the time-independent
Schrodinger equation.
We're going to be thinking about
the electromagnetic radiation
as waves rather than
photons, and that
means there is constructive
and destructive interference.
There's phase
information, which is not
present in the
molecules-as-targets,
photons-as-bullets picture.
Now I don't want you
to say, well, I'm
never going to think
this way because it's
so easy to think about trends.
And, you know, the Beer-Lambert
law, all these things that you
use to describe the probability
of an absorption or emission
transition, this sort of
thing is really useful.
OK, so this is the right
way, and the crucial step
is the dipole approximation.
So we have
electromagnetic radiation
being a combination of electric
field and magnetic field,
and we can describe the
electric field in terms of--
OK.
So this is a vector, and it's
a function of a vector in time.
And there is some magnitude,
which is a vector.
And its cosine of
this thing, this
is the wave vector, which
is 2 pi over the wavelength,
but it also has a direction.
And it points in the
direction that the radiation
is propagating.
And this is the
position coordinate,
and this is the frequency.
So there's a similar expression
for the magnetic part--
same thing.
I should leave this exposed.
So we know several things.
We know for
electromagnetic radiation
that the electric
field is always
perpendicular to
the magnetic field.
We know a relationship
between the constant term,
and we have this k vector,
which points in the propagation
direction.
Now the question is--
because we have--
we have a molecule
and we have the
electromagnetic radiation.
And so the question is, what's
a typical size for a molecule
in the gas field?
Well, anywhere?
Pick a number.
How big is a molecule?
STUDENT: A couple angstroms?
ROBERT FIELD: I like
a couple angstroms.
That's a diatomic molecule.
They're going to be
people who like proteins,
and they're going to talk
about 10 or 100 nanometers.
But typically, you can say
1 nanometer or 2 angstroms
or something like that.
Now we're going to shine
light at a molecule.
What's the typical
wavelength of light that we
use to record a spectrum?
Visible wavelength.
What is that?
STUDENT: 400 to 700 nanometers?
ROBERT FIELD: Yeah, so
the wavelength of light
is on the order of,
say, 500 nanometers.
And if it's in the infrared,
it might be 10,000 nanometers.
If it were in the
visible, it might be 100--
in the ultraviolet, it might
be as short as 100 nanometers.
But the point is that this
wavelength is much, much larger
than the size of a molecule,
so this picture here
is complete garbage.
The picture for the ratio--
so even this is garbage.
The electric field
or the magnetic field
that the molecule sees is
constant over the length
of the molecule to a
very good approximation.
So now we have this
expression for the field,
and this is a number which
is a very, very small number
times a still
pretty small number.
This k dot r is very small.
It says we can expand
this in a power series
and throw away everything
except the omega t.
That's the dipole approximation.
So all of a sudden, we
have as our electric field
just E0 cosine omega t.
That's fantastic.
So we've gotten rid of the
spatial degree of freedom,
and that enables us to
do all sorts of things
that would have required
a lot more justification.
Now sometimes we need to
keep higher order terms
in this expansion.
We've kept none of them,
just the zero order term.
And so if we do, that's called
quadrupole or octopole or
hexadecapole, and
there are transitions
that are not dipole allowed
but are quadrupole allowed.
And they're incredibly
weak because k
dot r is really, really small.
Now the intensity of
quadrupole-allowed transitions
is on the order of a million
times smaller than dipole.
So why go there?
Well, sometimes the dipole
transitions are forbidden.
And so if you're going to get
the molecule to talk to you,
you're going to have
to somehow make use
of the quadrupole transitions.
But it's a completely
different kind of experiment
because you have to have
an incredibly long path
length and a relatively
high number density.
And so you don't
want to go there,
and that's something
that's beside--
aside from what we care about.
So now many of you are going to
be doing experiments involving
light, and that will
involve the electric field.
Some of you will be
doing magnetic resonance,
and they will be
thinking entirely
about the magnetic field.
The theory is the same.
It's just the main actor
is a little bit different.
Now if we're dealing
with an electric field,
we are interested
in the symmetry
of this operator, which is
the electric field dotted
into the molecular
dipole moment,
and that operator
has odd parity.
And so now I'm not going
to tell you what parity is.
But because this has
odd parity, there
are only transitions between
states of opposite parity,
whereas this, the magnetic
operator, has even parity.
And so they only have
transitions between states
of the same parity.
Now you want to be curious
about what parity is,
and I'm not going to tell you.
OK, so the problem
is tremendously
simplified by the
fact that now we just
have a time-dependent
field, which
is constant over the molecule.
So the molecule is seeing
an oscillatory field,
but the whole molecule is
feeling that same field.
OK, now we're ready to start
doing quantum mechanics.
So the interaction term,
the thing that causes
transitions to occur--
the electric interaction term,
which we're going to call
H1 because it's a perturbation.
We're going to be doing
something in perturbation
theory, but it's time-dependent
perturbation theory,
which is a whole lot
more complicated and rich
than ordinary time-independent.
Now many of you have found
time-independent perturbation
theory tedious and
algebraically complicated.
Time-dependent
perturbation theory
for these kinds of
operators is not tedious.
It's really beautiful.
And there are many, many cases.
It's not just having
another variable.
There's a lot of
really neat stuff.
And what I'm going to present
today or I am presenting today
is the theory for CW radiation--
that's continuous radiation--
really weak, interacting
with a molecule or a system
in a single quantum
state initially.
And it's important.
The really weak and the CW are
two really important features.
And the single quantum
state is just a convenience.
We can deal with that.
That's not a big
deal, but it does
involve using a different, more
physical, or a more correct
definition of what we mean
by an average measurement
on a system of many particles.
And you'll hear the word
"density matrix" if you go on
in physical chemistry.
But I'm not going to
do anything about it,
but that's how we deal with it.
OK, so this is going
to be minus mu--
it's a vector-- dot E of
t, which is also a vector.
Now a dot product,
that looks really neat.
However, this is a vector
in the molecular frame,
and this is a vector in
the laboratory frame.
So this dot product is a
whole bunch more complicated
than you would think.
Now I do want to
mention that when
we talk about the rigid rotor,
the rigid rotor is telling
us what is the probability
amplitude of the orientation
of the molecular frame relative
to the laboratory frame.
So that is where all this
information about these two
different coordinate
systems reside,
and we'll see a
little bit of that.
OK, there's a similar expression
for the magnetic term.
I'm just not going
to write it down
because it's just too
much stuff to write down.
So the Hamiltonian, the
time-independent Hamiltonian,
can be expressed
as H0 plus H1 of t.
This looks exactly like
time-independent perturbation
theory, except this guy, which
makes all the complications is
time dependent.
But this says, OK, we
can find a whole set,
a complete set of eignenenergies
and eigenfunctions.
And we know how to write the
time-dependent Schrodinger--
the solutions of the
time-dependent Schrodinger
equation if this
is the whole game.
So we're going to use
these as basis functions
just as we did in ordinary
perturbation theory.
So H0 times some
eigenfunction, which now I'm
writing as explicitly
time-dependent is En phi n t
equals 0 e to the minus
i En t over h-bar.
So this is a solution.
This thing is a solution to
the time-dependent Schrodinger
equation.
And so when the
external field is off,
then the only states
that we consider
are eigenstates of the
zero-order Hamiltonian,
and they can be time dependent.
But if we write psi n star
of t times psi n of t,
well, that's not time dependent
if this is an eigenstate.
So the only way we
get time dependence
is by having this time-dependent
perturbation term.
OK, so let's take
some initial state.
And let us call that initial
state some arbitrary state.
And we can always write
this as a superposition
of zero-order states.
OK, and now, unfortunately,
both the coefficients
in this linear combination
and the functions
are time dependent.
So this means when we're
going to be applying
the time-dependent
Schrodinger equation,
we take a partial derivative
with respect to t,
we get derivatives
with this and this.
So it's an extra
level of complexity,
but we can deal
with it, because one
of the things that we
keep coming back to
is that everything we
talk about is expressed
as a linear combination of
t equals zero eigenstates
of the zero-order Hamiltonian.
OK, so the time-dependent
Schrodinger equation--
i h-bar partial with
respect to t of the--
yeah, of the wave
function is equal to--
OK, that's our friend
or our new friend
because the old
friend was too simple.
And so, well, we can represent
this partial derivative
just using dots because
the equations I'm
going to be putting on
the board are hideous,
and so we want to use
every abbreviation we can.
This is written as a product
of time-dependent coefficients
and time-dependent functions.
When we apply the
derivative to it,
we're going to get
derivatives of each.
And so that's the
left-hand side.
OK, and let's look at this
left-hand side for a minute.
OK, so we've got something
that we don't really
know what to do with, but this
guy, we know that this is--
this time-dependent
wave function
is something that we can use
the time-dependent Schrodinger
equation on and get
a simplification.
So the left-hand side--
I haven't written
the right-hand side.
I'm just working on
the left-hand side
of what we get when we start
to write this equation.
And what we get is we know that
the time dependence of this
is equal to 1 over i h-bar
times the Hamiltonian operating
on phi n.
Is that what I want?
I can't read my
notes so I have to--
I have to be--
yeah, so we've just taken
that 1 over i h-bar.
This is going to be the
time-independent Hamiltonian,
the zero-order Hamiltonian.
And we know what we get here.
Yes?
STUDENT: So all
your phi n's, those
are the zero-order solutions?
ROBERT FIELD: That's correct.
STUDENT: So they're
unperturbed states?
ROBERT FIELD: They're
unperturbed eigenstates of H0.
And if it's psi n of t, it
has the e to the i En of t--
En t over h-bar factor
implicit, and we're
going to be using that.
All right, so what
we get when we
take that partial derivative,
we get a simplification.
OK, let me just write
the right-hand side
of this equation too.
So we have the simplified
left-hand side,
which is psi n c--
I've never lectured on
time-dependent perturbation
theory before.
And so although I
think I understand it,
it's not as available in
core as it ought to be.
OK, so we have this minus--
where did the wave function go?
Well, there's got
to be a phi in here
and then minus i over h-bar En
cn t over the times phi n of t.
That's the left-hand
side in the bracket here.
OK, and the right-hand side
of the original equation,
that is just some n cn t
En plus H1 of t phi n t.
OK, it takes a
little imagination,
but this and the
terms associated
with that are the same.
This happened when we did
non-degenerate perturbation
theory.
We looked at the
lambdas of one equation.
There was a cancellation
of two ugly terms.
And so what ends
up happening is we
get a tremendous
simplification of the problem.
And so the left-hand side of
the equation has the form,
and the right-hand side has
the form over here without
the extra term--
sum over n, cn of t
H1 of t psi n of t.
OK, and now we
have this equation.
We have this simple
thing here, and we
have this ugly thing here.
And we want to simplify this
by multiplying on the left
by psi F of t so--
and integrating
with respect to tau.
F is for final.
So we're interested
in the transition
from some initial state
to some final state.
So we're going to massage this.
And when we do that, we get--
I've clearly skipped a step,
but it doesn't matter--
i h-bar cf dot of t is equal
to this integral sum c n of t
integral cf of--
phi f of t H1 f of
t phi n of t, e tau.
This is a very
important equation
because we have a simple
derivative of the coefficient
that we want, and it's
expressed as an integral.
And we have an integral
between an eigenstate
of the zero-order Hamiltonian
and another eigenstate.
And this is just H1 f n of t.
OK, so we have these guys.
So what we want to
know is, all right,
this is the thing that's
making stuff happen.
This is a matrix
element of this term.
Well, H1 of t, which is
equal to v cosine omega t
can be written as v times
1/2 e to the i omega t plus e
to the minus i omega t.
This is really neat
because you notice
we have these complex
oscillating field terms,
and we have on each of
these wave functions
a complex oscillating term.
And what ends up happening
is that we get this equation.
i h-bar cf dot of
t is equal to--
and this is-- you
know, it's ugly.
It gets big.
A lot of stuff
has to be written,
and I have to transfer
from my notes to here.
And then you have to
transfer to your paper.
And there is going to be--
there will be printed
lecture notes.
And in fact, there may actually
be printed lecture notes
for this lecture.
But if they're not,
they will be soon.
OK, and so we get this
differential equation, which
is the sum over n c n of t
integral psi f star of t times
1/2 v, v to the i omega t
plus e to the minus i omega
t times psi n of t, e tau.
Well, these guys
have time dependence,
and so we can put that in.
And now this integral has
the form psi f star 0 1/2 v,
and we have e to the minus
I omega and f minus omega t.
Omega nf, the difference in--
so omega nf is En
minus Ef over h-bar.
And so we have minus this
oscillating term, minus omega
t, and then we have e to the
minus i nft plus omega t.
So here this isn't well, it's
so ugly because of my stupidity
here.
But what we have here
is a resonance integral.
We have something
that's oscillating fast
minus something that's
oscillating fast.
And we have the same
thing plus something
that's oscillating fast.
So those terms are zero because
we have an integral that
is oscillating.
I'm sorry.
It's oscillating between
positive and negative,
positive, negative.
And as long as omega is
different from omega nf,
those integrals are zero because
this integrand, as we integrate
to t equals infinity
or to any time,
is oscillating about
zero, and it's small.
However, if omega is the
same as minus omega nf
or plus omega nf, well, then
this thing is 1 times t.
It gets really big.
Now we're talking about
coefficients, which
are related to probabilities.
And so these coefficients
had better not
go get really big because
probability is always
going to be less than 1.
OK, so what we're
going to do now
is collect the rubble in
a form that it turns out
to be really useful.
So we have an
equation for the time
dependence of a final state, and
it's expressed as a sum over n.
But if we say, oh, let's
make our initial state
just one of those.
So our initial state is--
let's call it ci.
And we say, well,
the system is not
in any other state other than
the i state, and this is weak.
So we can neglect all
of the other states
where n is not equal to i.
And if they're not
there, cn has to be 1,
so we can forget about it.
So we end up with this
incredibly wonderful
simple equation.
So we make the two
approximations.
Single state, the
perturbation is really weak,
and we get cf of t
is equal to the vfi--
the off-diagonal
matrix element--
over 2i h-bar times the
integral from 0 to t e
to the minus i omega i
f t minus omega times
e to the i omega
i f plus omega dt.
Well, all complexity is gone.
We have the amount
of the final state,
and it's expressed by a
matrix element and some time
dependence.
And this is a resonant situation
where if omega t, omega t--
if omega is equal
to omega i f, fine.
Then this is zero,
the exponent is zero,
we get t here from that.
And we get zero from that one
because that's oscillating
so fast it doesn't do anything.
But that's a problem because
this c is a probability.
And so the square of c had
better not be larger than one,
and this is cruising
to be larger than 1.
But we don't care about cw.
What we really
care about-- well,
what is the rate as
opposed to the probability?
OK, because the rate
of increase of state f
is something that we can
calculate from this integral
simply by taking the--
we multiply the
integral by 1 over T
if the limit T goes to infinity.
And now we get a
new equation, which
is called Fermi's golden rule.
OK, so I'm skipping
some steps, and I'm
doing things in the wrong order.
But so first of
all, the probability
of the transition from
the i state to the f state
as a function of time.
So the probability is
going to keep growing.
That's why we want to do this
trick with dividing by t.
What time is it?
OK.
That's just cf of t
squared, and that's just
the fi over 4 h-bar squared
times this integral 0 to t e
to the plus and e to the
minus term dt squared.
OK, the integrals survive only
if omega is equal to omega i f.
And if we convert to a
rate so that the rate is
going to be Wfi, which is
going to be Vfi over 4 h-bar
squared times the sum of
two delta functions Vi
minus Ef minus omega plus sum
of Ei minus Ef plus omega.
So the rate is just
this simple thing--
the square matrix
element and a delta
function-- saying either it's
an absorption or emission
transition on resonance,
and we're cooked.
OK, so now I want to
show some pictures
of a movie, which will make this
whole thing make more sense.
This is for a
vibrational transition.
So we have the electric field--
the dipole interacting
with the electric field.
And now let's just turn
on the time dependence.
OK, so this is the
interaction term.
We add that interaction term
to the zero-order Hamiltonian,
and so we end up getting a
big effect of the potential.
The potential's going
like this, like that.
And so the eigenfunctions
of that potential
are going to be profoundly
affected, and so let's do that.
Let's go to the next.
All right, so here now we
have a realistic small field,
and now this is small.
And you can hardly
see this thing moving.
OK, now what we have is
the wave function of this.
And what we see is if omega
is 1/4 the energy, if omega
is much smaller than the
vibrational frequency
or much larger, we get very
little effect of the time
dependent.
You can see that the
wave function is just
moving a little bit.
The potential is
jiggling around,
whether the perturbation
is strong or weak.
It's not on resonance.
And now let's go
to the resonance.
Now what's happening
is the potential
is moving not too much,
but the wave function
is diving all over the place.
And if we ask, well,
what does that really
look like as a sum
of terms, the thing
that's different from the
zero-order wave function
is this.
So zero-order wave function
is one nodeless thing.
This is the time-dependent term,
and it looks like V equals 1 So
what this shows is,
yes, there are--
if we have a time-dependent
field, and it's resonant,
then we get a very
strong interaction
even though the field is weak.
And it causes the appearance
of the other level
but oscillating.
And so resonance is
really important,
and selection rule
is really important.
The selection rule for the
vibrational transitions
has to do with the form.
Oh, I shouldn't
be rushing at all.
OK, so let's draw a picture.
And this is the part that has
puzzled me for a long time,
but I've got it now.
So here we have a
picture of the molecule.
And this end is positive,
and this end is negative.
And we have a
positive electrode,
and we have a
negative electrode.
So that's an electric field.
And so now the positive
electrode is saying,
you better go away, and
you better come here.
So it's trying to
use compressed bond.
And now this field
oscillates, and so it's
compressing and expanding.
Now that's what's going on.
But how does quantum
mechanics account for it?
Well, quantum mechanics says
in order for the bond length
to change, we have to
mix in some other state.
So we have the ground state,
and we have an excited state
that looks like that.
And so the field is
mixing these two.
Now that means that the operator
is mu 0 plus derivative of mu
with respect to the
electric field times q.
So this is the thing that
allows some mixing of an excited
state into the ground state.
This is our friend the
harmonic oscillator--
operator, displacement operator.
It has selection rules delta
v equals plus or minus 1,
and that's all.
So a vibrational
transition is caused
by the derivative of the--
yeah, that's-- no, derivative of
the dipole moment with respect
to Q.
So did I have it right?
Yes.
So this is something--
we can calculate how the
dipole moment depends
on the displacement
from equilibrium,
but this is the operator that
causes the mixing of states.
So one of the things I've
loved to do over the years
is to write a cumulative
exam in which I ask, well,
what is it that causes a
vibrational transition?
What does a molecule
have to have in order
to have a vibrational
transition?
And also what does
a molecule have
to have to have a
rotational transition?
Well, this is what causes
the rotational transition
because we can think of the
dipole moment interacting
with a field, which is going
like that or like that.
And so what that does is it
causes a torque on the system.
It doesn't change
the dipole moment,
doesn't stretch the molecule.
It causes a
transition, and this is
expressed in terms
of the interaction
mu dot E. This dot
product, this cosine theta,
is the operator
that causes this.
We call the relationship between
the laboratory and the body
fixed coordinate
system is determined
by the cosine of some angle,
and the cosine of the angle
is what's responsible for a
pure rotational transition.
And we have
vibrational transitions
where they are derivative
of the dipole with respect
to the coordinate.
Now let's say we have nitrogen--
no dipole moment, no derivative
of the dipole moment.
Suppose we have CO.
CO has a very
small dipole moment
and a huge derivative of the
dipole moment with respect
to displacement.
And so CO has really strong
vibrational transitions
and rather weak
rotational transitions.
So if it happened that CO had
zero permanent dipole moment,
it would have no
rotational transition.
But as you go up to higher
V's, then it would not be zero.
And you would see
rotational transitions.
And so there's all sorts of
insights that come from this.
And so now we know what
causes transitions.
There is some
operator, which causes
mixing of some wave functions.
And the time-dependent
perturbation theory
when it's resonant
mixes only one state.
We have selection rules
which we understand just
by looking at the wave fun--
looking at the matrix
elements, and now we
have a big
understanding of what is
going to appear in a spectrum.
What are the intensities
in the spectrum?
What are the transitions?
Which transitions are
going to be allowed?
Which are going to be forbidden?
And that's kind of useful.
So there is this
tremendously tedious algebra,
which I didn't do a very
good job displaying,
but you don't need it
because, at the end,
you get Fermi's golden
rule, which says
transitions occur on resonance.
Now if you're a little
bit off resonance,
well, then the stationary phase
in the oscillating exponential
persists for a while,
and then it goes away.
And so you get a little bit
of slightly off-resonance
transition probability, and
you get other things too.
But you already now have
enough to understand basically
everything you need
to begin to make sense
of the interaction of radiation
with molecules correctly,
and this isn't
bullets and targets.
This is waves with
phases, and so there
are all sorts of things you have
to do to be honest about it.
But you know what
the actors are,
and that's really
a useful thing.
And you're never going to
be tested on this from me.
OK, good luck on the
exam tomorrow night.